[Music]
were you disappointed by halo 5s lack of
split-screen multiplayer I know I was
but there's good news for both of us as
halo 6 or whatever the next game the
series is called will definitely have
split screen support I'm Matt this is a
game spot news update and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for all the news
about the next big halo game 343
industries executive Bonnie Ross said
during her dice beach that not including
split-screen multiplayer in halo 5 was
one of the big mistakes microsoft made
after taking the reins on the halo
franchise she added that every
first-person shooter developed by the
studio going forward will include split
screen Halo franchise director Frank
O'Connor said in 2015 that the blowback
from Halo fives lack of split-screen was
huge but he added that it was
technically impossible to patch the
feature into the game the game's locked
frame rate of 60 frames per second is
partially responsible for this and the
team implemented it knowing that it
would create some issues as for the next
halo game we'll keep you updated as more
is revealed but if you want some
first-person shooter action right now
check out our video on the bizarre
aliens and weapons of prey